So, back at the beginning of February 2019 DJ marshmallow performed a live
concert inside Epic Games' online gaming
sensation Fortnite, and I have since
then being informed via numerous breathy
think pieces that Fortnite is no longer
merely a game but is now a content
delivery platform experience and so
logically the only sensible thing for me
to do is to get in on this and pivot
entirely to Fortnite.
Welcome to the brand-new Folding Ideas
all Fortnite digital studio that is not
only a digital studio because I'm
producing digital content but it is also
literally a digital studio. It is double
digital. And this this arm-waving emote
is the only meaningful animation I've
got and there's nothing available that
really looks like talking so I,  I guess
it's what I'm going with for now. So when
you see me doing this it means I'm
talking to you.
It took me like 20 hours to unlock this.
Fortnite, developed by
Epic Games, is an online four-player
cooperative base-building tower-defense
shooter game released as "early access
with in-game purchases" in July 2017. The
game has since been utterly eclipsed by it's
free-to-play sub-game Fortnite Battle
Royale launched in September 2017.
Battle Royale, a format popularized by Playerunknown's Battlegrounds and originally
inspired by the 2000 Japanese horror
film 'Battle Royale' is a last player
standing free-for-all where 100 players
are dropped onto an island with an
ever-shrinking zone of engagement and
left to scrounge resources, build defences,
and fight until only one remains. In the
wake of the success of Fortnite Battle
Royale the original Fortnite has been
renamed Fortnite: Save the World.
A critical bit of Fortnite's development
comes from the involvement of Chinese
multimedia firm Tencent. In 2012 Epic Games
approached Tencent for help with the
then-fledgling Fortnite seeking their
input on turning the game into a live
service platform, meaning it would
function as an ongoing revenue stream
rather than simply being a single
purchase product. Tencent agreed to help
and supply additional financial
resources and expertise in exchange for
being allowed to purchase a 40% stake in
the company, an arrangement to which Epic
agreed. Following the merger a number of
high-profile staff retired from Epic
including Cliff Bleszinski, Adrian
Chmielarz, Lee Perry, and Rod Fergusson;
all to one degree or another citing
dissatisfaction with either the Tencent
merger, the games as a service business
model, or both. But that's not what you're
here for.
You don't want a history lesson placing
Fortnite into an appropriate
cultural context. You're here for hot
Fortnite player on player action.
It's "player versus player"
wait what did I say
so remember to follow me on twitch TV
slash I kill weed names because you can
enjoy what the earth-mother gave us but
that isn't the same as having a personality.
one of the things in particular that
stands out to me about the
meta-narrative surrounding Fortnite~
hey, isn't it weird how hostile the
free-to-play track is? Like it's not
simply structured to drive paying for
something or another it actually starts~
Okay so what's all basic about a concert~
Okay, so what all this about a concert in Fortnite? An February 2nd
2019 Christopher Comstock, who performs
under the DJ name Marshmello, played a
10-minute concert in Fortnite's
Pleasant Park
Or, more accurately, at 2:00 p.m. Eastern
Time players who joined a special
Marshmello concert game-mode got to
watch a scripted concert event during
which weapons and damage were
deactivated to ensure that players
couldn't be griefed and that the event
wouldn't be interrupted with gunfire and
explosions. It's maybe a bit of a
pointless hair to split, the fact that
the concert was pre-recorded and not
actually live, but I mean that's what we
do here. We deconstruct narratives and
the idea that this was a live set was
very much part of the narrative. The
fiction extended to the fact that the
mini set was added to Marshmello's tour
schedule. A significant component of the
implicit messaging was to demonstrate
the flexibility of Fortnite, the concept
of Fortnite as a content delivery
platform. As a scripted event utilizing
the game's engine, server architecture,
and assets the concert is quite
impressive. The crowd does end up looking
a little thin because it turns out 60
people per match just isn't that many if
you're trying to simulate an actual
audience, but players manoeuvring virtual
bodies need a bit more space to do
things than real people, and keeping the
population low mitigated problems with
players who were accessing on lower end
hardware or internet connections,
minimizing the odds that they would lag
out or just crash entirely. As a delivery
platform however? Well it demonstrates
the flexibility and possibilities that
fortnight offers if your DJ Marshmello.
The concert isn't actually built in
Fortnite. It's full of bespoke assets
and scripting that could only be
constructed with the active
participation of Epic Games.
While Fortnite has a creative mode that
allows players to build their own spaces,
even very impressive spaces, nothing like
this is remotely doable. While it's
possible to put on a concert in
Fortnite, it's not possible for you to
put on a concert in Fortnite. The actual
audience for this specific message is
big-name collaborators. Epic is
advertising the idea that Fortnite is a
viable venue for crossover promotional
opportunities. This is all part of the
concept of games as a "live
service" so we should probably spend some
time disassembling that particular
narrative concept.
Fortnite isn't really a game. Like
there's a game attached to Fortnite but
that's not the core of Fortnite.
Fortnite is first and foremost a
storefront. The monetization systems in
Fortnite Battle Royale
are seemingly simple on their face, but
well join me on a journey. The two arms
of for Fortnite's monetization are the
battle pass and the item shop, both of
which are fueled by an in-game token
currency called V Bucks. V Bucks are used
here, as in most other micro transaction
based games, as a means to bypass
financial regulations involving held
value and some regional laws surrounding
gambling with regards to loot
crates, because in many regions it
doesn't count as gambling if the
currency involved is non-fungible.
Basically in a lot of places it doesn't
legally count as gambling if you're
gambling with fun bucks that can't be
converted back into legal tender, so
things that utilize all the structure,
vocabulary, and psychological mechanisms
of gambling, like video game loot crates
or Gachapon toys, aren't technically
gambling as far as the law is concerned
because you can't convert your winnings
directly back into dollars. Additionally
the use of V Bucks also allows Epic to
obfuscate the assigned value of both
in-game purchases and the value of
V Bucks themselves by giving buyers a bulk
discount for buying more, and handing out
V Bucks for performing in-game
activities.
Nominally one V Buck is worth just under
one US cent, but if you buy 10,000
V Bucks at a cost of $99.99 u.s. you get an
air quote bonus 3,500
so the actual monetary cost of anything
you buy on the store varies by about 25
percent depending on how many V Bucks
you bought. If you're confused that's the
point.
The primary utility of funny-money is to
relieve you of the pressure and weighing
if this specific skin is worth fifteen
dollars... or is eleven dollars? This is on
top of another really common strategy
where the amounts don't scale evenly and
don't line up cleanly with the costs of
actual items, increasing the likelihood
that you'll always have some left over
or will need to buy a substantial amount
in order to get the thing that you
want. This particular bit is pretty
common but Fortnite manages to take it
to a whole new level. This is ultimately
the meaning of "game as a service": it's
just a euphemism for a game that takes
up all your free time and becomes the
only game that you play because it's
just an elaborate, constantly resetting
Skinner box that utilizes progression
systems and seasonal competition as a
means to place you constantly in the
path of an endless stream of monetary
interactions. To top it off as a game
Fortnite Battle Royale isn't even
particularly great. The matchmaker is
utterly bare-bones and pays no regard to
your performance so you'll almost always
be matched to the mix of players who are
barely functional and several who are so
far above your skill level that you're
not even really playing the same game.
The building mechanics in Battle Royale
are unwieldy and create a tremendous
skill gap that contributes to the afore
mentioned disparity, but they're also the
whole gimmick that the game is built
around so that's kind of take it or
leave it.
The game is full of weird unpolished
edge cases like vehicles all using
slightly different control schemes even
for shared functionality. You get on a
hoverboard and the speed boost is bound
to left-shift but on a quad crasher
boost is spacebar, even though left shift
isn't bound to anything on the quad
crasher. Because of the way that systems
interact, in particular the ways that the
building mechanics are vital for
defending against long-range attacks but
are also so effective for either closing
distance or escaping that the mid-range
effectively barely exists. The game
biases extremely heavily towards
shotguns, basically becoming a contest of
closing distance and gaining height so
you can land a shotgun headshot on your
opponents. If you strip out everything
else the game is a moderately okay
shooter with a unique twist and a
compelling aesthetic. It's not dire, but
it's kind of just barely good enough to
stand on its own without the rest of the
hooks. And oh boy does Fortnite have
hooks. The item shop is pretty grotesque
when you break down its underlying
mechanics. In contrast to pretty much
every other game on the market Fortnite
only displays 10 to 13 items at a time
rotating on a daily basis.
This has the dual purpose of obfuscating
what's available and creating a FOMO
response or fear of missing out. If you
see something you like you have a
limited window in which to purchase it,
and with the total inventory of products
obfuscated there's no sense of how long
it might be until that particular item
is available again or even if it will
ever be available again at all.
Incidentally Alfonso Ribeiro isn't just
suing epic because his Carlton dance
made it into the game, but because they
took his work and were selling it for 8
bucks a pop. The other arm of the
monetization system is the Battle Pass
which costs a little under $10 u.s. and
ties into the seasonal progression track
system which is itself broken into two
tiers: freed and paid. Fortnite cyclical
gameplay is broken up into ten weeks
seasons and the battle pass applies only
for a given season. The paid track just
throws piles of stuff at you every tier
to incentivize playing more, including an
early perk of an experience boost next
season just in case you were maybe
considering not getting the next battle
pass ten weeks from now. What's
interesting about the free track is that
it doesn't merely make use of FOMO
psychology. It's not just saying "oh look
at all this stuff you'd get if you
bought the battle pass." Though, I mean, it
is literally saying that right there. But
in addition to that it's making use of
hostile design. The free track actually
ends at tier 62. Though the season track
goes until 100 there's no additional
free rewards past this point. From here
it's not simply a matter of a fear of
missing out. The entire battle pass
system is founded on the dopamine rush
of unlocking something new every few
hours of play to keep players coming
back. Within that context the point where
the game stops giving you stuff entirely
the game is withdrawing the thing that
it used to get you hooked. It is
punishing you for having dared play this
long without paying. This is manufactured
discontent. And make no mistake you will
have to play a lot to get to this point.
Again with the layers of deliberate
obfuscation, the broad progression
systems are broken into two parts: first
account level, which is
itself broken into total level and
seasonal level, and the Battle Pass which
we've discussed. Progressing in level is
done by earning experience which is
rewarded at the end of every match while
progressing the battle pass is done by
earning battle stars.
Battle stars are rewarded in amounts
ranging from two to ten for every level
and for completing challenges which come
in daily and weekly flavors. Daily
challenges tend to be fairly
straightforward, ranging from placing in
the top twenty five to scoring a number
of takedowns with a specific weapon type,
while weekly challenges tend to get more
varied and abstract and include things
like visiting specific locations on the
map. Now briefly I want to touch on the
psychological design elements of the
weekly challenges and the way that
they're presented. First there's the
element of FOMO in that the completion reward
of 5,000 XP, a substantial amount of
experience, requires completing four
challenges but only three are available
for free. Second the paid battle pass
challenges aren't simply locked but are
turned into a mystery box. If you don't
pay you don't even get to see what they
are. Tantalizing isn't it? You only need
one more. You're so close. Well let's go
back to these tracks. They're presented
as roughly analogous, literally in
parallel, but progression along these
tracks aren't even. The gold tier players
have access to more challenges which
reward more battle stars which in turn
reward direct experience on top of
experience multipliers. Gold players
don't just get more they get it faster
and with less effort. So this point, tier
62, it's highly unlikely that you'll
actually get to this point without
playing a lot of Fortnite every single
day. I've actually needed to play a lot
of Fortnite pretty much every day in
the course of making this video, both in
order to ensure I understood the game
itself well enough to speak about it
confidently, and also just to get these
specific kinds of footage I was looking
for.
And at the midpoint of season 8 I'm less
than halfway there.
This maybe seems like I'm just
complaining about the free-to-play
players not getting enough stuff, but
that's not actually the point.
The underlying purpose of demonstrating all
this is to show the mechanisms that the
creator's are willing to employ. These
psychological tricks are in effect a
form of rhetoric, a form of persuasive
speech. They are trying to persuade you
by applying select forms of pressure and
it is, I think, worth understanding the
mechanisms of that pressure so that we
can better recognize how and when we are
being persuaded. Also it's worth keeping
in mind that as a season is only ten
weeks long a paid player can slip back
into being a free player at any time.
In order to retain all the perks of being a
paid player one would need to buy all
four to five season passes every year.
All of this goes hand in hand: the
Marshmello concert isn't a thing
happening in parallel to the
monetization systems, it's a core pillar.
The external purpose of things like this
are fairly straightforward. It's a
publicity stunt, an oddity that people
will talk about. The cost of assembling
the technical aspects of the concert and
paying Comstock for his participation
were effectively weighted against a
direct ad buy, and based on the coverage
Epic/Tencent is probably pretty happy
with the outcome. The internal purpose is
a little more arcane and I wouldn't
blame you if you wanted to use the word
sinister. The purpose of the concert is
to utilize the social pressure of
exclusion. Let's take a closer look at a
couple key moments.
Let me see everybody doing that Marsh Walk right now let me see that Marsh Walk
Find your squad then let me see your favourite emote let me see what you go let's go
Alright I want to see everybody doing their favourite emote right now on the drop let's go
if Marshmello is calling out for you to
use your favourite emote, well if you
haven't paid in odds are you don't have
any or the ones you do have are going to
be pretty generic and lame. Events like
the concert create environments where
the ability to self express is placed at
a premium. In order to feel like a full
and active participant you need to be
able to perform. The catch is that
literally every unique action has an
attached price tag.
Let me see everybody doing that Marsh Walk right now, let me see that Marsh Walk
and there are some things that you'll simply never get
without paying. Players who haven't
bought a skin don't even have control
over their basic image. There isn't a
roster of default looks to choose from;
your look is assigned randomly after
every match. There isn't just a layer of
FOMO, the sense that others around you
with cooler, more expressive character
models are having more fun, are better
able to project themselves into the
social space, there's a level of
hostility in the design. If you don't buy
in you aren't merely limited in your
options of expression, you are actively
denied control over the most basic
element of how you choose to look in the
virtual world. Nothing that Fortnite
does is particularly new. These complex
monetization systems with multiple
layers of obfuscation, you can find this
in pretty much any mobile game, and
plenty of desktop and console games are
laden with cosmetic microtransactions,
legally dubious gambling, and other ways
to aggressively monetize the game. Lots
of games use progression systems and
incremental rewards as part of their
core loop to keep players playing.
Fortnite is really just a maturation of
those systems, a refinement of every
habit-forming trick and micro
transaction pressure point developed in
the last decade condensed into a
weaponized product targeted at kids. One
of the articles that originally called
my attention to all of this was one Nick
Statt wrote for The Verge titled
"Fortnite's Marshmello Concert was a
Bizarre
and Exciting Glimpse of the Future". I
disagree with Nick's breathy excitement, but
on the whole he's right. Fortnite is a
glimpse of the future. An awful,
perpetually monetized,
vertically-integrated,
vaguely hostile future.